unlike men women actually have to be
asked to run for office very few women
put themselves forward and so you have
to actively go out and recruit them so
you'll see a lot of men sort of raising
their hands and saying I want to run I
want to run with women and it would have
a lot of the recruiters that I've spoken
to have said with women they really ask
a thousand questions before they even
consider running what would it be like
for their families what would it be like
for their jobs what would be like for
their incomes what what happens with
their children do they have to move what
are the schools like and so it takes a
lot of convincing to get a woman to run
for office versus a man so the good news
is that there is in the recruiting
process increasingly a number of women
running who are young mothers which has
actually been the hardest demographics
to get people to run because they
obviously have young children they don't
know that they want to be running for
Congress let alone working Congress
which seems like an intense job or
running for president I'm running for
governor any or any of these offices are
very you know sort of hardcore but you
see a lot more younger women running now
because they feel that not only can they
balance work in life because their
husbands are stepping up more to help
take care of the kids and do the house
works but also they feel that they've
come to realize that these jobs are
actually pretty flexible so you can you
know unless you're voting you can pretty
much do anything you want with your
schedule you can go to your kids soccer
games and then do your work later on you
can have your meetings in the morning
you can have them in the afternoon you
can you know so the schedules are the
schedule flexibility tends to be really
key to women and in that sense politics
is a really good thing for them so
hopefully you'll see a lot more women
going into this and you see certainly a
lot more women going into the public
sector these days than the private
sector so that is some reason for hope
and some good news
my aesthetic of discussions are based
off of a book that I'm writing which is
essentially about how women reach a
tipping point so some are between 20 and
30 percent women begin to really change
outcomes less than that and they don't
really have an impact but more than that
they change outcomes vastly so for
example in the last session of Congress
113 Senate you saw there were 20 women
in the Senate for the first time ever
they actually not only ended the